[Applaudissements]
sa maman luigi comment ça va louis j ça
fait plaisir de te revoir
imitons là aussi ça va manquer mais nous
apprirent you mean i au caire rocher né
en france est ça va être plus simple
annonce suit les élections américaines
toute la nuit ils veulent une batte en
anglais mon vieux tu vois le tenir un
thibaut vous êtes beau gosse à vous êtes
musclée vous êtes sympas et énervant sur
un an n'a pas joué non mais franchement
petit bout c'est le mec
même si les beaux gosses un même si tu
as envie d'être son pote à moi je pense
est vrai nom est ce que tu sais qui va
pas de piquer sa mère comme il est droit
et à leurs droits et des trois arrivées
vers moi et moi non voilà par exemple et
le moi j'adore quelqu'un ici c'est
benjamin castaldi on peut skomina
problèmes de vue et bien mais j'ai pas
vu que c'était voilà mr gil jourdan
plus' les faillites
vous avez bien raison mais on aime comme
ça allez bon si vous n'avez pas ce
problème et vous êtes quand même le mec
que les mecs aiment bien détester c'est
normal nous avait tous les talents
d'ailleurs le magnéto s'appelle thibault
a tous les talents
[Musique]
après avoir cartonné avec ses vidéos
fitness retrouver thibault in shape
dresseur animalier l'abri c'est encore
sa gamme de poterie pour la fête des
mères à transforme doucement
thibault in shape au cinéma dans son
court-métrage pipi du voisin et enfin
thibault in shape en chanson avec son
duo exceptionnel avec gilles verdez le
père c'était le père d'une abonnés et en
fait on avait fait une sorte de concours
et tous et il avait gagné ce concours là
une chanson la team shaper s'étaient
rencontrés en effet un clip ensemble et
c'est une personne voilà qui vit toute
là toute la vie dans sa voiture et tout
est simple salamé petit peu mis en avant
on le fait aux bisous bisous si voilà
une belle initiative à thibaut cauwet
exactement alors vous formez un des
couples les plus tendances de france
avec votre chéri juju fitia l élan plus
sains du gène hla hla goûtez moi ça va
mieux
elle surveille allait surveiller à
surveiller toutes les filles et les
chrétiens rentrée c'est la grande
gagnante de votre concours miss inside
créé spécialement dans le but de trouver
l'amour à peine j'ai parlé de jouer au
bureau un tout le monde va dire à
thibaut une chaîne justifie 4,6 sont
trop mignons ils sont trop mignons et
c'est regarder vos vidéos et c'est vrai
que vous êtes vraiment trop mignon
attention il faut venir manger avec tes
parents à table dû me lever talent pour
édifier il sied de l'oat c'est vrai
qu'il ya des couples qui osent pas
laisser la porte ouverte mais vos
toilettes mais nous aussi suis l'un
l'autre
écoutez c'était la première fois on
s'est vus je vais vous êtes un couple
glamour
on les appelle les essuie-tout
merci tu nous avais 7 8 millions
d'abonnés sur youtube 4,2 millions
d'abonnés sur instagram et 3.5 millions
de muscles différents rien que dans
votre bras gauche du cou atp mp ça nous
a mis aussi la pression et nous aussi on
a tenu à vous accueillir au top de notre
forme savez je vous présente design chez
sony ça lui va bien
gilleen chérie tu m'as bien fait ça très
bien
ben non ça ne change pas c'est fini
philippines celle de jean michel saive a
bien
[Applaudissements]
dauphin de trucages et c'est
naturellement musclée vous êtes-vous dit
évidemment je sais que vous entraînez
d'urs meier thibault est ce que vous
connaissez fred seconde peau oui avec
j'adore sermonnant exactement ouais ça
mais faute d'avoir fred c'est bon
mangez-en pression c'est un très très
bon pote à moi témoigne d'ailleurs fred
qui sont très nerveux scène champion du
monde de bodybuilding et sa propre
émission de muscu à l'époque et ça
ressemblait à ça regardez salut à tous
salut toi derrière ses lunettes de prof
de maths fred a été mister univers la
preuve il fait faire des haltères avec
des bouteilles
et pas mal mais ce jour-là fred recevez
une star du paf
bien connu pour sa musculature de folie
animateur incontournable
il court de succès en succès depuis des
années mais que fait-il pour garder la
forme on va le savoir tout de suite en
accueillant benjamin castaldi l'exercice
de malades s'asseoir ici ce sont les
gens qui vendent bien partir sur l'avant
on va ce bien calés poser les fesses
provenaient en serrant ses fesses à
l'efb ngo se concentrer pas de l'âne
foireuse te plaît voilà parfait moi
c'est facile c'est tout aujourd'hui
moi j'aime beaucoup de cheval ouais
j'aime bien mon témoin est qu'à sa salle
et pas seulement sportif hors pair ou un
animateur de génie c'est aussi un
comédien de folie avec à 27
alors justement toussa toussa toussa
font attendre et césaire 10 mai acteurs
et à travers l'examen castaldi
[Applaudissements]
dix ans et benjamin castaldi l'était
fracasse sur le canapé l'arrivée alors
dernier recalé de fitness est un sport à
la mode en ce moment mais attention
thibault vous vous êtes un professionnel
donc ça se passe bien hélas pour qui tu
ça se passe un peu moins bien c'est dans
le zapping du fitness pas mal zapping
fitness et bien on a retrouvé jean
michel maire en pleine séance de pont
valérie bénaïm à la salle pour bosser
les abdos haye
le cousin de jean claude van damme qui
travaillent jardiland
on a eu des images du mec qui faisait
des haltères dans son cul on exclut la
prochaine doublure de spider-man 5
[Musique]
jean michel maire en pleine séance de
rameurs et toujours spider man 5 bientôt
sur vos écrans
merci